und Robert Habeck möchte ab kommendem
Jahr das Öl und Gasheizungen nicht mehr
neu eingebaut werden dürfen und dann
soll es einen schrittweises Verbot geben
bis endgültig 2045 keine einzige Öl und
Gasheizung in diesem Land mehr am Netz
ist und für Wärme sorgen kann das eine
riesen Problem und zwar aus
verschiedenen Gründen es gibt zum einen
gar nicht genug Alternativen wenn man
mit den Verbänden spricht beispielsweise
den wärmepumpenherstellern oder
Herstellern anderer alternative
Heizungsarten dann sagen die wir werden
das gar nicht schaffen es gibt 8
Millionen das Etagenheizungen
beispielsweise in Deutschland und es
gibt doch keine richtige Technik wie die
eigentlich ausgetauscht werden sollen
ist das und das ist jetzt nicht nur
meine Meinung sondern auch die viele
Experten was Robert habe dort plant
absolute
Utopia und das wird höchste Zeit das
Robert habe als Traumtänzer von seinem
Seil ohne Netz und doppelten Boden
hinuntersteigt und endlich realistische
Politik macht